but what are a six can we remember them
we've written them a lot of tires out
where did we begin hey yep
wow that was a little advanced we did
get to do the power zero but that bet
took a while for us to get there didn't
it right I think we start with
multiplication first didn't we right
what time zone hey power of something
something else what do we do to the
indices good+ and we added the indices
together good there was a version of
same law before division right so here
and what we did need this is now we
subtract good okay excellent so far so
good from all of these we got the zero
power the zero index right because we
saw all if these two are the same these
numbers you know safe was any power n
divided by an apparent something divided
by itself is always equal to 1 that's
right so that's what we got that result
from and then we looked at the zero
power zero as well we took a lot of time
to do that ok now the most recent laws
we did they're all interconnected to
each other they have to do with brackets
do you remember what it was no I want to
try
I'll give you click it starts of the day
this is this is the most resourceful so
we call this power all the power right
so it's like something cubed and then
that you square the whole thing right
power power
so what happens here so these two pads
how do they relate to each other
yep crossing sounds like this doesn't it
she's a different in it right it's
multiplication yeah that's right it's
like this okay or if you like for sure
just mmm you know sometimes we just
leave off the multiplication sign
okay yeah that was a fourth index law
power of power and had two very very
similar cousins I had this guy when
you've got two others in there
right so you've got a product and then
they get raised to a power like they're
you get get square to something what
happens to both of them yeah then they
both get that power this power gets left
onto both numbers okay so you're gonna
get this a.m. and BM okay it's very very
similar to this one okay last one just
like from one to two we went
multiplication to division here we even
go multiplication to division so if I
had divisions like so okay what do we
conclude about that
just like before you're gonna get a.m.
and BM but cuz its division not
multiplication you get division yeah
okay and that's where we stopped right
now before I go on I just wanna
influence to you like these things here
that were this list that we've been
developing it's very important that
we've been developing it like I didn't
just you know first lesson okay everyone
memorize the ten commandments of indexes
you know that got indices and why are
they true because you know just just
memorize it right just learning do you
remember like each one it sort of grows
out of the previous ones right like we
got this one from these two and we got
these ones from this okay so they kind
of us just try to work out what are the
rules of the game and how do they all
lead to another